i was spelling the word biosphere down
the phone to people
people didn't know what a biosphere is
and so
biosphere put not just the word
biosphere in our lexicon but the concept
the idea of what a biosphere is
and you know that's a that's a hugely
important and transformative idea for
humanity that we now
have you know this short form our global
biosphere i think we all basically have
a general understanding of what that
means now and you can really thank
biosphere 2 for that
pete we've talked about isolation a lot
on the show
it seems like uh yeah like once every
third show yeah we've talked about it in
in relation to space like the
international space station
stanford tourists in a smaller respect
and uh
maybe even on other planets smart space
colonization exoplanets as well we've
also talked about it
in relation to this planet because we've
talked about living in isolation during
a pandemic
uh we talked about seasonal affective
disorders that as it all sort of
pertained to that
lockdown era that you know we're in now
and uh you know there's multiple ways to
sort of imagine what that scenario would
be like
yeah well unfortunately it's gone from
imagining to yes
to real world scenarios yeah we know
more than we've ever known
about isolation but
we still don't know what it would be
like to live in a closed
biosphere you know who knows that
there's some people there's very
few people on this planet many who
actually know the answer
well how many have lived in a closed
biosphere
for two years eight people and one of
them is
joining us today wow and her name is
jane pointer jane
perfect welcome to what if discussed
well hello there gentlemen hello it's
been a while obviously since and you
were such an integral part of obviously
not just
you know participating in the biosphere
2 project
but also being part of the design uh
leading up to it
and really the legacy work after a lot
in in terms of the you know where that
science is being applied now but
i guess the first place to start i know
it's just such a big question but
what was your experience in biosphere 2.
so maybe it might be helpful before we
talk about how i experienced living in
biosphere 2
just to sort of set the table a second
and let everybody know what biosphere 2
is was right so i was on the design team
of this sounds very grandiose but it's
true
it's we were on the design team of
humanity's first attempt at creating
the world's first human-made biosphere
right so we all live in a biosphere
that's biosphere 1
the earth and we were attempting to
create
biosphere 2 the first other biosphere
and so
it was a three acre and still is it's
still going today and is run by
university of arizona
uh it's a three acre enclosed
environment that was completely sealed
back in the day it was
was sealed when i was in there tighter
than the international space station
so there was essentially no air exchange
with outside
and so all of the plants inside the
rainforest
the savannah the ocean the marsh the
desert
and the farm were creating all of our
oxygen
you know we were creating some of the
co2 for all the plants and so everything
was recycling inside and we drank the
same water over and over again
and breathed the same oxygen over and
over again
so one of the incredible things
about being inside biosphere 2 was
that experience it was that experience
of being
viscerally part of my biosphere and
really understanding what it is to have
a finite biosphere
and for eight people visual too was
pretty small
uh and it turns out that's very akin to
the kind of
experience that astronauts have when
they see the earth from space
they see the earth from the outside in
so they see the boundaries of this
planetary biosphere that we all inhabit
and they too have a similar experience
of
holy cow our earth is not that big
yeah so it was an amazing experience it
was also very hard because you know as
you were talking about in the intro
being isolated is not
necessarily the easiest thing no
that's and that's what i think we're
talking about and you just mentioned
with
astronauts i would think are the most
isolated people
but after that this is a huge isolation
but
to go into something like that really
you know you really have to have a
courage and
and some sort of sense of an explorer's
curiosity obviously you had that
why do you think you were so willing to
do this
so it had nothing to do with being
willing it was like i had to do it
i was on the design team and so was i
seriously going to let somebody else go
in and test
this out of course i had to go in and it
was
also the closest thing i ever thought i
would get to mars
so for me this was almost like going in
and testing a prototype space base as if
we were on mars and my
favorite place to be was sitting on the
beach that we had
looking out the incredible windows that
were everywhere
and we were in the arizona desert and at
sunset the mountains around us
turned red and so for all the worlds we
were on mars so i
for me it was living out this
extraordinary live stream of of going to
mars
and it's interesting you say that
because i think not everybody but a lot
of people
that you know i've talked to about this
you know they seem to remember or
equate biosphere 2 with you know an
environmental ecological endeavor which
of course it was again a lot of the
science a lot of the recycling all those
things but in the end
the impetus was what would it be like to
live
on another planet yeah so that was
really
something that was you know let's say
ahead of its time
at the time over the course of the last
x amount of years jane
you know you see movies like the martian
i could go on and on in the sci-fi world
how much and how i don't know what
what's it been like for you to
watch these people sort of apply some of
those things
in pop culture and sci-fi going forward
as it relates to living on other planets
well i i absolutely loved the martian
uh it was very true to life
i mean as i was watching it i was like
uh-huh that's right
but one of the that's what i'm thinking
like one of the people who are watching
that movie going
well that's absolutely accurate or that
isn't
well you know and of course the author
did a really good job of getting
scientific input into what he was
writing so that was also very cool and
it was very apparent so i absolutely
loved it and it's thrilling so look i've
been in
in this the human space flight world my
entire adult life
uh and you know i thought back in the
day when we were biosphere 2
we would be well on mars by now and at
the time
america did have a plan to go to mars
but
you know as we know plans change so
uh what's been super exciting is to
really see what's going on with
commercial space
and you know that that's really taking
off
uh in such a huge way you know it's sort
of almost
an overnight success that's been many
decades in the making
uh so it's it's very exciting to see
that
you know and i think what's uh what's
super
interesting and relevant
about space flight and human space
flight is that it has this really unique
power to inspire right there's really
few other things that i think really
capture the world in its entirety and
and
and get people excited as space flight
does
you know and and we were talking a
second ago about astronauts and
and their experience of seeing earth
from space
and one of the things that i'm really
drawn by is these sort of huge ideas and
so the huge idea of being able to give
being able to give as many people to see
out from space is incredibly
important because you know with all of
these extraordinary global challenges
that we have right here in biosphere 1
how important is it that we are based in
a global perspective
so i think this uh human space flight
whether it's with a biosphere eventually
or you know the kind of spacecraft that
we see with the international space
station is
really really important yeah a few years
ago i i
interviewed the late great uh edgar
mitchell
sixth man to walk on the moon cool he
you know obviously as you would think
right somebody who's an astronaut back
in the day well what what's their
background usually
they're science people they're military
people they're rigid
i don't want to say rigid but you know
what i mean they're structured they're
not hippies
yeah let's just say that right
discipline well he comes back
from having that experience and he i'm
sure you're familiar with this jane but
he articulates what jane's talking about
it transformed him to see the
the earth like and i don't mean just
like he changed i'm gonna
no he means he felt rewired from seeing
the earth
on its own i mean other astronauts have
talked about that but
it actually changed the entire course of
his life after that he started the
institute for noetic sciences
and he he talked about it almost like a
almost like a religious experience jane
yeah so actually that's very common uh
and now we're beginning to see
what i will loosely say as sort of
quantifying
what happens to people who go to space
and have this experience you know i
think uh you know
i'm paraphrasing but there's the um
commentary that you know we're going to
space to explore space and instead we
discovered the earth
uh and and what happens and now you can
see it actually changes behavior
literally it changes people's behavior
you know like me going into biosphere 2
i was all about space i'm going to mars
that's my only focus environment who
cares and you know when i came out of
the biosphere i was like oh
wait a minute yes i'm a bisperian too
we're all bispherians of planet earth
and we should care and it's important
and what you'll see with
uh astronauts when they go to space it's
very similar they go up
maybe they're involved in you know some
social activities a little bit of
environment when they come back
there's a statistically significant
increase in the amount of
interaction they have with their
communities
and how involved they get with
environmental and social causes of of
many kinds it really
is striking how it impacts
us as a human to get that
place understand our place in our global
biosphere
so i guess all we need is to get
everybody into space yeah
well yeah that's what i'm working on but
that's another song you were lucky
enough to go
and experience that so that's obviously
your perspective there are many other
perspectives on the success of biosphere
2
but uh like a lot of things with the
benefit of time we see more and more the
value of
what we learned from biosphere 2 as it
helps guide other projects and science
and
but what do you think is the most
important legacy of biosphere 2
so of course there's there's many
aspects
of uh science that
uh biosphere 2 has directly
impacted and climate change science and
biogeo
cycling uh all kinds of particular signs
about understanding how our planet works
but when i really boil it down
you know one of the things that we have
to remember is
putting biosphere 2 in its historical
context
so we were designing biosphere 2 in the
1980s
and i went inside in 1991.
you know there was barely an internet
you know people were hardly you got to
really put yourself back there right i
was
spelling the word biosphere down the
phone to people
people didn't know what a biosphere is
and so
biosphere put not just the word
biosphere in our lexicon but
the concept the idea of what a biosphere
is and you know that's a that's a hugely
important and transformative idea for
humanity that we now
have you know this short form our global
biosphere i think we all basically have
a general understanding of what that
means now and you can really thank
biosphere 2 for that
yeah absolutely and there's so much more
i mean i'm
i'm sort of boiling over here with
questions because i really want to get
into the experience of being there but
also
you know the social aspect of eight
people all the other things the oxygen
issue
can you stick around jane for a few more
questions
sure no problem so excellent we'll
follow up with jane
on the audio version yeah we'll continue
to delve into all things biosphere with
jane poynter in the extended audio
version of what if discussed
if you're watching this on youtube right
now just click on the link below
if you're already listening on the
podcast well just stay tuned
and if you can't continue this journey
with us well thanks
as always for joining us on what if
[Music]
discussed